What would be the best possible input for the algorithm.
The best possible input for the algorithm would be if we give it a string that does not contain
the letter a at all because this rates at a to 0, so the overall running time will be 2n+0a+1,
which is this constant here.
Now, in the worst case, the string will just consist of a's and this will set a equal to n
because each of the letters in the string will be added, and so if a=n,
then the overall running time is 32+0a+1.
Now, the great thing about this here is that in both cases, both with a best-case view
and with the worst-case view, we have eliminated the dependence on a,
so we know that no matter what string the algorithm receives, the running time will always be
between 2 and +1 and 3 and +1.
Now, you could also say--why didn't we ask you to analyze the average running time
or the running time for an average input and that is simply because it's very hard
to define the notion of average.
Does an average string, for example, contain only half of the letters as a
or is it at end of sentence, in which case the number of a's will be very low.
Unless we have a very precise view of the term average,
the running time here would be very hard to define.